great pleasure to introduce our very
special guest this evening
Ken Burns has been making documentary
films for more than 25 years
his films range in scope from two-part
biographies of some of America's most
important men and women such as Thomas
Jefferson frank lloyd wright lewis and
clark susan b anthony to multi episodic
films like the Civil War baseball and of
course jazz burns film the Civil War was
the highest-rated series in the history
of American Public Television and was
honored with more than 40 major film and
television awards his film Brooklyn
Bridge was nominated for an Academy
Award and the series baseball won the
Emmy Award for burns historian Stephen
Ambrose has said more Americans get
their history from Ken Burns than any
other source
mr. burns remarkable gift for taking
history and making it breathe even
pulsate with life has earned him the
unofficial title of America's
documentary maker as well as our
collective gratitude and respect his new
10 part series is called jazz it's
airing now on our local PBS station here
in Washington WETA
episode 5 swinging a pure pleasure airs
tonight on WETA at nine o'clock so you
might be able to catch it after the
event so you have to race home but you
now have the great fortune to meet the
man behind America stories in person so
now all you hep cats and chicks please
put your hands together for mr. Ken
Burns
thank you thank you very much I'm very
pleased to be back here in the capital
district because my presenting station
WETA is from here I get a lot of support
from the National Endowment for the
Humanities this is where it all begins
and of course this is where the civil
war began as well so it's great probably
right unter Ettore right around here
it's great to be back that was a very
generous introduction I saw Steve
Ambrose today and I teased him that he
must regret that now that he sells
millions and millions of copies of his
own books but but he's terrific and and
all of that praise reminds me of a
cartoon I have on my refrigerator it's
now 22 years old and old and yellowing
and it shows two men standing in hell
the flames licking up around them and
one guy says to the other apparently my
over 200 screen credits didn't mean a
damn thing but I'm glad you're here and
I know that I'd much rather have a
conversation with you and your questions
I'm sure going to be very interesting
but I wanted to set the the table a
little bit and since we don't have a
screen I can't show you all 17 and a
half hours of the film you'd be out by
Oh tomorrow at noon but I would like to
tell you a little bit about us Genesis I
see this film as the third part of a
trilogy on American life that I began in
1984 with when I started working on the
Civil War series I wish I could tell you
that this was a trilogy I had in mind
from the beginning but it is not I
started work in 1984 on the history of
the Civil War because it was something I
did not know enough about and it also
seemed to be the deciding force in all
of the other films I had worked on the
Brooklyn Bridge my first film would not
have been built without this new metal
called
which the war helped to promote and
indeed the man who built the Brooklyn
Bridge Washington Roebling would not had
gotten his practical training as a
bridge builder during the Civil War the
Shakers the subject of my second film
they declined precipitously after the
Civil War not just because of the
economic and social changes that took
place in America but the psychic changes
that took place in a country that had
just murdered six hundred and thirty
thousand of its own people my next film
was on the Statue of Liberty that was
originally intended as a gift from the
French to mrs. Lincoln to commemorate
the survival of the Union despite her
husband's ultimate sacrifice and my
fourth film on Huey Long the southern
demagogue he came from a dirt poor North
Louisiana parish that thought the
Confederacy was a rich man's cause and
had talked about seceding from the
Confederacy and so became a hotbed of
populism and radicalism that eventually
spawned that swamp thing called Huey
Long and finally my fifth film was on
the history of the Congress in which its
greatest test was when there were two
congresses one in Washington DC and
another in Montgomery and later Richmond
so all around me was the Civil War and
it compelled me to do it it took nearly
six years to make and while I was
working on it I knew that I would follow
it up with a simple film a short film I
thought on the history of baseball
something I had given me great pleasure
as a child but which is history I knew
very little about but as I began to work
on baseball the sound of Shelby foots
voice was echoing that the Civil War was
the defining moment it was the
crossroads of our being he said and I
began to realize that we are so wedded
to history as just a political military
narrative of wars and generals and
presidents and we think that can stand
in for American history and it just does
not tell us enough about who we are but
in this simple children's sticking ball
game I was finding out in a way what we
had become after the Civil War the
baseball series talked about immigration
and assimilation
and the badge of citizenship that was
worth more than a piece of paper from
the State Department playing in this
pastime this is about the tension the
ever-present tension between owners and
workers the people who played in the
field and the people who brought the
ball this was a story about the
exclusion of women I'm sorry to say
about the nature of popular culture and
advertising of heroes and villains and
fools of great American cities their
birth and decay and now I'm pleased to
say their rebirth and of course this was
about race the thing that had caused the
civil war you could find the story
manifested in baseball as well because
how could we call it a national pastime
if it took until April 15th 1947 for
Jack Roosevelt Robinson to become the
first African American to play in the
game so all of the themes that had
animated the Civil War and more were
issuing in baseball and I in a Blake Ian
sense the poet William Blake I felt you
could find an American universe in the
grain of sand of baseball just after the
Civil War I gave a speech at the
Metropolitan Museum as part of the
american academy of achievement and i
was giving it principally on black
soldiers and their role in the civil war
and I was quite excited about that I've
been passionately interested in the
question of race since I was a little
boy and sitting in the front row was
Wynton Marsalis and after it was done he
greeted me quite generously and said you
know man you should do something on jazz
and at that point I thought I don't want
to be told what to do
III choose my own topics you know or
they choose me the topics choose me but
it planted a seed and then we had the
great good fortune in baseball to do an
interview with Gerald early who is a
great writer essayist for a time was the
chairman of the African American Studies
department at Washington University in
st. Louis and he said this remarkable
thing that worked itself into the
introduction of the baseball series he
said that when they study our American
civilization 2,000 years from now and I
assume by they he meant archaeologists
when they study our American
civilization 2,000 years from now which
is
longtime Americans will be known for
only three things the Constitution
baseball and jazz music he said that the
three most beautifully designed things
Americans have ever done so that was the
second jazz thing and I had begun to use
in my films Huey Long even Brooklyn
Bridge bits of American jazz as I was
animating these films and I realized how
little I knew about it my father had
played jazz music in the house growing
up I had worked in a record store
through all of high school and briefly
ran it and so knew all about it
but my music was R&B and rock and soul
and and not jazz and I had only a
handful of jazz records in my collection
but the more and more I thought about it
the more and more I realized that I had
to tackle this just ultimately Americans
subject and I realized that what Gerald
early was telling to me was that the
genius of America is improvisation
that's how I interpreted what he said
that the genius of America is
improvisation the Constitution is four
pieces of paper just four pieces of
paper written at the end of the 18th
century that's able to adjudicate our
most complicated problems in this the
new 21st century except for Florida
baseball is a simple children's stick
and ball game nearly every culture has
something like it and yet in this
culture it has transformed itself into
something akin to the Japanese noh drama
with infinite chess-like
combinations and at the heart of the
only art form that Americans have
invented is this simple notion that I do
not necessarily have to play the notes
on the page I can play Who I am and in
the communication of Who I am and what I
feel
art can be created just as we said we
could govern ourselves and have in fits
and starts done a pretty good job of it
just as we have transformed this simple
game into a magnificent mirror of our
dreams and our aspirations our concepts
of time and memory family and home so -
if I claim to be interested in American
history of lifting up that hood and
looking under it to find out who we are
I had to tackle this extraordinary
subject and so for the last six years
this is what I have engaged myself and
the team of remarkable people who work
with me to do it is much more than a
story of this fascinating music and the
amazing human beings human beings in the
same right as the generals and
politicians of the Civil War or the
baseball heroes from that series people
who belong in the pantheon of
Americanism
but it is much more than that this is a
film that is in some ways using jazz as
an opportunity to be a window into the
soul of America this is a mirror jazz is
a mirror that reflects back at us where
we've been good and bad over the last
100 plus years and it is a prism through
which we can see refracted so much more
than this music and those individuals so
this series becomes in a way a history
of the 20th century it is about two
world wars and a devastating depression
and the soundtrack
got Americans through the most difficult
of times this is a film about sex the
way men and women speak to one another
through music a complicated and
sophisticated and elegant ritual of
courtship a mating call that has all but
disappeared from our popular music today
this is a film about drug abuse and the
terrible terrible cost of addiction this
is a film again about great cities and
this is a film about race
how ironic how poetically just that
those individuals most responsible for
the creation of the only art form
Americans have invented should have a
historical memory of being unfree in a
supposedly free land
you know when Thomas Jefferson wrote our
Creed all men are created equal he owned
more than 200 human beings and never saw
fit in his lifetime to free them and so
set in motion this fault line of race
that has not only bedeviled but in noble
the American experience in the 200 plus
years since he wrote those words and we
know where it manifests in tragedy like
the Civil War when we had to murder
ourselves in order to settle that
question we know where it manifests in
frustration and impatience in the story
of baseball why did it take so long why
did we have to have the separate but
athletically equal negro leagues but we
also have this glorious art form this
affirmation in the face of adversity
this sort of conscience of who we are
and our possibilities and so we found in
the story of jazz the idea that this was
not just a history of where we've been
but a kind of key to a redemptive future
possibility of where we might go what we
might become if we were to rise up and
live out as dr. King said the true
meaning of our Creed do not
misunderstand me ladies and gentlemen
jazz is not black music jazz is not
African music jazz is American music
shared generously by the
african-american community with everyone
in this country
and now the world it would not be an art
form if that were not so if it was only
something that was black music or
African music it would be an indigenous
folk music which the rest of us could
only imitate and copy it is not it has
transformed itself into an elegant
elegant art form that will commend us to
posterity for long as there is a memory
of this country I began work on this
knowing so little the music has gotten
under my skin it is the mote it was the
most challenging of all the films I've
worked on and and therefore I think in a
way the most satisfying you will have to
be the judge of it we're in the middle
of it tonight is the fifth of ten
episodes and I hope you do have a chance
and please excuse me for making you come
out so early I know you usually do this
a little bit later but I don't want to
be caught dead in public while my film
is on I want to get back and watch it
hopefully with the rest of you all and
tonight is a particularly exciting time
I i've spoken much more than i said that
i would i know that you've all or many
of you have written down some questions
and i'll try to answer as many as we can
and then i'll try to sign as many books
as we can for you but i'm very pleased
to see you all here tonight and this
doesn't work and if i am just telling
you what I know about jazz that's the
problem I think with too many
documentaries they're merely the
expression of someone's already arrived
at and the actual production is just to
them telling you what it's about if
however the filmmaker goes into it and
decides that the work is itself a
process of discovery then I can share
with you as equals
I can I can talk up to you and not down
to you and that's what we try to do with
all of the series and I think that that
is in no small measure accounted for the
reason why you have rewarded me with
your attention not just this evening
but for all of these films and I am
extremely grateful for that thank you so
I'll get to some questions
this is a good question it says why is
the jazz community so divisive when it
comes to defining what jazz is it seems
like there's a reluctance to experiment
and change I don't think there's a
reluctance to experiment and change I
think that by the very nature of jazz is
so Restless and constantly experimenting
that some people in the community get
caught up with a few problems that it
must always experiment experiment for
the sake of experimentation and
sometimes lose sight of the art you know
most of us have moved away from jazz it
used to be 70% of the music industry now
it's down to single digits and it's time
that we reclaim it there are people in
Finland more people per capita in
Finland in Japan in Israel in France all
around the world who appreciate our
music better than we appreciate it just
as many people around the world
appreciate freedom better because they
don't have it or don't have it as much
as we have it but it's time that we go
back and embrace it and one of the
resistance that I had and I'm sure you
have too - jazz is that there's a
general assumption and I think that the
Jazz arathi have are responsible for
that that you have to have some sort of
advanced degree or some sort of esoteric
knowledge you have to have taken jazz
101 right to it to get with it it's just
a little bit too complicated and we feel
intimidated and by it and that we think
that unless we have a beret and a goatee
and live in Greenwich Village this music
is not for us am i right nothing could
be further from the truth Louis
Armstrong said there ain't but two kinds
of music in this world good music and
bad music and good music you tap your
foot - and I did not let out one single
episode of this film until every visitor
to the editing room was not only paying
rapt attention to the stories we were
telling but we're tapping their feet as
well and I think it's time to sort of
reclaim jazz from those who would
actually be frightened that it would be
popular again to reclaim jazz from those
who believe that you have to have some
esoteric knowledge to reclaim jazz from
those who would proclaim a kind of
Orthodoxy of what is and what isn't we
took a very ecumenical stand about jazz
we looked at all sorts of varieties of
it that our advisors came from every
stripe and we had no ax to grind no ism
to support just to celebrate what has
been a century of American music good
question was it difficult to interview
Artie Shaw Artie Shaw as you know is one
of the great great clarinet players of
all times one of the great leaders of
the swing band one of the greatest
greatest jazz musicians and we had the
great good fortune to interview him I
did not do the interview my co-producer
Lynn Novick who has been my stalwart
partner on these films since the last
days of the Civil War through baseball
and Frank Lloyd Wright and now jazz did
that particular interview with Artie
Shaw and it's one of the best we have in
the film I think if you've seen the
series today you've seen him a few times
including a biography of him tonight
there's a much more full portrait of
Artie Shaw and his concerns about the
commercialism of swing and then on
episode 7 which will be next Tuesday
night which many people think is the
finest of all the episodes about world
war 2 he describes his war experience
and sharing his music with troops
overseas and this crusty feisty genius a
man I've now met and talked to and loved
I think will bring you close to tears it
wasn't difficult Lynn loved him first
thank you so much for this series as a
person who developed my musical taste in
the R&B of the 60s in the funk of the
70s I appreciate the knowledge of your
series however I've heard so called jazz
critics say you shortchange contemporary
jazz artists how do you respond that's a
really excellent question and there has
been a great deal of criticism of the
series and to some extent is quite
legitimate our series begins in the
early 1800s with all the musical
ingredients and
up to about 1975 and then we unhitch our
narrative and for the last 40 minutes of
the film cover the last 25 years
I think celebrating the diversity of
jazz over the last 25 years celebrating
the diversity of jazz now and looking
very much to a promising future I think
jazz is coming up enjoying a kind of
Renaissance but I'm in the business of
history and history is about stories
that are over the last 25 years is about
stories that are ongoing that is the
province of jazz critics and writers
right now so necessarily they're quite
upset and and their noses are out of
joint because I'm not talking about what
they write about every day I can't do
that because I don't have the historical
perspective to do that and I made this
decision not at the end of this
production I made it at the very
beginning that we would not go farther
than that and we would celebrate
impressionistic aliy the last 25 years
did the same thing with baseball got the
same sort of complaints but I think it's
better to set in motion this history to
understand what we know and we can say
with confidence is a fairly agreed-upon
canon of jazz and allow us to be brought
to this present moment and in fact when
I confront many of those critics who are
some of them are my friends and deeply
disappointed I remind them that if I did
any justice to the last 25 years this
series would have to be another 17 and a
half hours long and it would no longer
be history it would be performance and I
think we would lose a lot of people had
already strayed from jazz or perhaps
have not been interested in jazz at all
but I asked them and I challenged them
to say who among today's players is the
equal of Louis Armstrong Duke Ellington
Charlie Parker Dizzy Gillespie Miles
Davis John Coltrane Thelonious Monk
Charles Mingus and there is total
silence and if I do elicit an answer
what they say is invariably it will take
us a couple of decades to know if that
is true
I rest my case you said you were
finished making documentaries on America
but why don't you consider making one
about the history of the American
Indians I am NOT finished making
documentaries about America if God gave
me ten thousand years to live
I would not exhaust the possibilities of
exploring those strange and complicated
people who like to call themselves
Americans and in fact in 1996 PBS
brought out a series that I made with my
friend Steve Ives called the West and
was told as much from the perspective of
Native Americans as it did from European
settlers European descendants and so I
invite you to look at that it doesn't
mean and Lewis and Clark also dealt with
that I'm I'm moving into in the next
decade to do films on the history of the
national parks and they will inevitably
engage the question of Native Americans
so it's a subject that I have visited
many times before and will continue to
visit can you share an anecdote which
reveals how your art of filmmaking can
sometimes be improvisational it was not
until jazz that I suddenly realized how
very much like improvisation what we do
is we are guided by discipline by
scholarship we write scripts we do
interviews but we do so with an openness
that is not as I said before an attempt
to describe to you what we knew going in
but have the finished product be what we
finally understood on the last day of
work on the series and so every day is
constantly balancing the need to be
improvisational people ask how many
researchers do you have I have none with
just a handful of us producers and
writers that do that research its
researchers one of the lowest career
rungs on a documentary production
company we would rather make those
critical decisions and not just saying
yes to a photograph at an archive but no
if someone says no I will never see that
photograph again and so it's a very
close-knit group of people who do that
we go out and film in the archives
hundreds of them what we're drawn to
visually unconcerned with whether
there's a scene in the script that this
is going to illustrate and conversely we
do not write the scenes in a script
worried about whether their images to
illustrate it we avoid the use of the
word illustration preferring to find
kind of visual and literary equivalents
that will help bring the story alive
we do not pre-interview the people we do
not coach them about what to say they do
not rehearse every time you see a
talking head they don't know nor do I
that they are gonna fit into a / a place
in the script we usually don't have the
script when we're doing the interviews
we're asking them questions we're
listening to them collecting a body of
responses which we then in the most
difficult part of our process editing
tried to find a place for so if any of
you saw the first episode of jazz where
Wynton Marsalis pauses for 14 seconds
dealing with the question of race after
you've heard of quote read by his friend
Harry Connick jr. impersonating the
words of Nick LaRocca and early white
jazz man who said african-americans had
nothing to do with jazz and you hear his
pause he that was an answer to a
question I'd asked him five years ago
about race before I'd even heard of Nick
LaRocca
so you can see what our editing process
is constantly improv is it or E that we
might take a part of soundbite number 57
of Wynton and move it next to Gary
Giddins in Episode six and then take
kittens and move it back to two and
that's what we do for years and years
and years until we think we get it right
I'm trying to make a documentary what do
you find is the most difficult thing to
do given this format what kind of camera
do you use
I used an at on a French camera 16
millimeter and an air flex SR the great
thing and the perilous thing about
making documentaries is that there is no
career path
I remember meeting I remember meeting
Robert Penn Warren the first poet
laureate of this country and an amazing
human being and I was very proud to say
a friend of mine for the last years of
his life and he looked at me one day
with these sort of snapping turtle
goggle eyes and said remember careerism
is death and I rarely use the word
career I always try to say professional
life when I'm referring to what I do at
my job because I'm still terrified he's
been dead more than ten years and he
said this to me more than 15 years ago
but I'm still scared of some hand that
will reach out if I say career too much
and that is a blessing and a curse it's
obviously a curse in that you have to
take the road not taken' you have to
find your own way and it's a blessing
for exactly those same reasons that no
two
documentary filmmakers are alike there's
not enough money to go around night now
we're really struggling even though
there's a proliferation of reality based
programming there's just not enough
money to go around there's not enough
support and there's not enough
programmers willing to take bold risks
would you consider a documentary on
public television is but a narrow
spectrum of the kind of work that's
being done by independence by people who
are pushing the boundaries of the art of
film and it's it's it would be an
important addition to our cultural life
if if these were supported they are not
and it forces us into improv is a Tory
modes all the time but the advice I give
people are cliches and platitudes it's
just two things one be yourself there's
a lot of apparent glamour to making
filmmaking that disappears the minute
you begin it and if you weren't sincere
about your interests you cannot do it
and sincere that you know how to make a
film that's really important and the
other thing is perseverance I know of
lots of great filmmakers and lots of
great ideas that don't get made because
there's just not enough follow-through
and my own good fortune is as much
perspiration
as inspiration would you like to do a
documentary on the history of rock and
roll if so I would love to be a part of
it please please please
I actually don't think I'd do a thing on
rock and roll which I love
I think it's I'm now getting to know
jazz see it as a pale pale but an
outgrowth of jazz music and and I was
interested in the way art and culture
intersect and the kind of free electrons
that a legitimate art form gives off in
collision with a public however I'm
toying around the idea of doing
something on Elvis Presley because
that's biography running on all
cylinders and that would have that would
of course engage rock and roll and if
you're a hound dog I'll see you after
the show I've seen bits and pieces of
jazz what do you think of European
cross-pollination namely Django
Reinhardt and his quintet do a Hot Club
de France we have a section on Django
it's really good the great thing about
this music is that it came up and out of
the African American community shared
with everybody and now overseas there
people in Sweden who swing as well as we
do in the 20s there was a sort of
fascination with all things African and
African American in Paris and in Europe
and so jazz was embraced the French have
never stopped criticizing us for our
inability to deal with race and yet we
will have a secretary of state who is an
African American who used to be the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
there will be a period not too long in
the future when there will be an African
American as a vice president as a
president they dominate our television
landscape you cannot say that about
France we are dealing with this question
and I think Europeans have seen in jazz
music a sense of freedom that they have
yet to experience themselves and finding
it liberation from European traditions
and there's no commentary on European
traditions it's just to say that
we have in this experiment in this
continent offered an alternative born
out of the monumental hypocrisy of
slavery but transcended that crime to
produce extraordinary things in this
country not the least of which is jazz
and what Europeans do just adds to it
it's a gigantic artistic feedback
machine that's the nature of jazz and I
welcome anybody who could play it any
predictions on the future development of
jazz will it continue to influence rock
Latin and other pop music or do you fear
it may become a great music but frozen
within the 20th century
Jim Ellington that's that's the person's
question thank you
I don't know historians in particular
amateur historians make lousy
prognosticators I know that jazz isn't
as popular as it once was but that
doesn't mean it's important or not
influential and you quite correctly
understand that it is the source music
that feeds all the streams of American
music in all of these R&B and soul and
rock and hip-hop and rap and pop music
are all out gross in some way shape or
another of jazz and if you're curious
about the the lightweightness of the
sense that it's fast food you need only
go over to Jazz's house no I don't get
me wrong you need to have a burger and
fries and go to the drive-up window
every once in a while but if you want
that sumptuous elegant feast you're
gonna get it from jazz music and I see
people experimenting in many different
strains and maybe there'll be an
Armstrong that'll come by and suddenly
jazz will be our popular music but the
music doesn't need a biographical hero a
great man theory to rescue it it doesn't
need rescuing there may be a collective
impulse to jazz that will capture our
imagination there may be an intersection
with popular music that will change
popular music and jazz will be
reintroduced into the mainstream but
it's undoubtedly it will continue to
influence things you listen to even rap
records and the rap producers will tell
you how much how influential jazz is
when choosing a subject to a film for 18
and 1/2 hours what criteria to use to
hold the viewers interest as you have
done with all your projects my only
master
Aristotelian poetics Aristotle sort of
said about as much as I can think about
how things should be and as long as
these are as demanding that as they are
of your attention we think that within
the confines of a single episode we can
hold your attention if you're willing to
give it we will deliver and it won't
fail I have heard of Li Mork and
trumpeter hey have you heard of Lee
Morgan trumpeter with Art Blakey 1958 to
1965 I have indeed he's one of the great
great great trumpet players and we have
a magnificent section by the way on Art
Blakey that'll come up in our ninth
episode he was a real University and
training ground for a lot of musicians
including Wynton Marsalis what was the
selection process you employed for the
narrators you use well I divided the
narrator's in half
third person narrator and first person
narrator first-person narrators or what
we call voices are those people reading
journals and newspaper accounts and
Diaries of the time and that is a
variety of people that I've used for 20
years new people that I've asked this
film enjoys the exquisite talents of
people like samuel l.jackson and Delroy
Lindo James Norton and Kevin Conway and
Duke in a many many great a Studs Terkel
Matthew Broderick lots of great people
who have read for us and they're very
generous with their time and clearly
with their talent the the narration the
third-person narrator and we call that
the narrator in this case is read by
Keith David an extraordinary actor who
has read first-person voices for me for
years but who has just I think made I
mean one of the best aspects I think of
this film is his reading of our
narration we are two student filmmakers
who are currently trying to produce a
film about jazz an independent feature
fiction where could we turn for funding
if it's fiction I don't know I've been
in the documentary community for too
long to know what the sources of our
additionally a fiction filmmaking
involves investing we're public
television documentary making involves
underwriting the investing the people
who give money expect to return those of
with the jazz project like General
Motors the National Endowment for the
Humanities the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting foundations like Pew
Charitable Trusts and Logan foundation
and the Park Foundation these type of
people who supported jazz do not look
for return and I think make it possible
for many of us to make these films
Satchmo grew up in a bad environment
that what what did he do to maintain a
sunny outgoing persona you know we're
talking about this earlier the great
revelation for me in this series was
Louis Armstrong when I began this
project to me he was a guy with a white
handkerchief who with a big winning
smile the Transformer of popular songs
like Hello Dolly it's a wonderful world
within weeks of beginning this project I
began to realize that he was probably
the most important person in American
music in the 20th century I did not say
jazz and I went back to our very diverse
two dozen members of our advisory board
who cannot agree about anything in fact
we could never convene them all together
because a fistfight would break out
probably over the size of the table let
alone a jazz question and I went back to
them assuming that some would agree in
some would shoot me down and it was like
I was saying the sky was blue Louis
Armstrong is too American music what
Einstein is to physics what Freud is to
medicine what the Wright brothers are to
travel and fortunately I've just
produced a series that can prove it in
nearly every episode and he
single-handedly transformed jazz into a
soloists art he invented for lack of a
better word what the critic Gary Giddins
called modern time or swing in fact in
the early days of swing what you'll see
tonight they didn't call it swing music
they called it orchestrated Armstrong
when
ameri-ghen was asked what he needed
during the arduous road trips that the
swing musicians play during the
Depression he said I need a toothbrush
and a picture of Louis Armstrong he then
transformed all of American singing
introducing scat to the rest of the
country singing so magnificently that
even today no one has ever matched the
virtuosity of his singing Dinah in our
fourth episode which was Monday night
and influenced every American singer
where they're aware of it or not
Bing Crosby the subject of great
celebration recently and Andy and the
subject of a great book by Gary Giddins
who's in our film
Bing Crosby said that Louis Armstrong is
the beginning and the end of music in
America not that it has an end but that
there's he's involved in every part of
it but I want to get to the question his
upbringing was horrible but we
interviewed a hundred people for the
film seventy-five make an appearance in
the film probably fifty talk about
Armstrong to us every single person
would describe his genius but then every
single person whether it was a critic a
writer or a historian a hanger-on a
family friend a musician now struggling
with his legacy and musician who played
with him they would all say the same
thing and as sober eyed critics and
academic historians they would say that
he was a gift from God
or an angel every single person would
say something like that and after a
while you begin to pay attention to this
I've come across this only once in
American history and that was with
Abraham Lincoln in which there was a
kind of mystical attachment to his being
to his presence to the kind of way that
he represented not only who we were good
and bad but who we could become and I
finally in the course of my travels ran
into a woman who for lack of a better
word I guess you described as a medium
or a psychic and I said what's going on
here everybody is saying that he is a
gift from God or an angel and she just
looked at me and smiled and said biggest
wings I've
I can't think of a better place to stop
than with that I hope you enjoy the rest
of the series and I look forward to
meeting you personally thank you